कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि नए
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम सीखने
वाले हैं जर्मन के इन रेगुलर भर और उनके
कुछ टाइम इधर-उधर मतलब क्या जो रूल को
नहीं मानते रूम मतलब क्या तो पहले ही
एपिसोड में अपने मंत्र सीखा था रिंगटोन
वाला अतिरिक्त में से यह को हटा और क्रीम
का स्टांप बनाओ इस शहर को यह लगाओ दो है
तो एसटीएफ है तो TV है तो इन स्ट्रिंग का
दूध बींस सब तैयार है तो बहुत सारी जर्मन
वर्ड्स जर्मन भर यह मंत्र फॉलो करते हैं
पर कुछ ऐसे हैं कि जो यह मंत्र पूरी तरह
से फॉलो नहीं करते तो आज हम ऐसे कुछ वक्त
देखने वाले उनके टाइम्स तो उसके बेसिकली 5
टाइप्स हम बोल सकते हैं उसमें दो तो आपको
आते हैं तो चलिए आइए हम वह सीखते हैं
का पहला टाइप में हमको सबको पता है यहां
पर हम और बजाय जब हमने सीखा था तभी हमने
बोला था कि यह रेगुलर है इस बाबत दूर हास
और जाए तो सबको बताया इस बिंदु पेस्ट एग्स
irregular है हो गया पहला आटा सेकेंड टाइप
मोड ऑफ वह भी हमने देखा था कैसे याद रख
हैं पैरिस में कानकुन झोल झोल अंधाधुंध
अगिन तिरिया तो देखो दोस्तों को ऑलरेडी
जाते हैं तीसरा जो है वह थोड़ा सर्वाइकल
अगर आप देखोगे फ्रेंड अब फ्रेंड है उसका
अगर आपको ऐड करना है तो कैसे वक्त प्रिंट
फील्ड फ्रॉम करने के लिए हाल है ड्राइड तो
इसी लिए हम उसमें भी देते फ्रेंड एट
फ्रेंड एट जब दूर और रूप हो उससे यहां है
और बटन और उनका यौवन हटाओ स्टॉर्म
रॉबर्ट एडवर्ड कर्म रॉबर्ट इंपॉसिबल इस्ट
स्पेन ग्रेट स्पीच तो उसकी नियुक्ति से
देंगे एयर अपॉइंटेड दूर टेस्ट तो बेसिकली
क्या है अगर आपके पास टाउन के एंड में
धोइए पीएम या एन आ रहा हो तो हम एक ही
एक्स्ट्रा देंगे जब दूर और बोलोगे वह
सिर्फ मोड़ने को इजी हो तब मेन रीजन देंगे
दूसरा वैसे ही अगर आपके पास टांग के एंड
में ऑलरेडी ऐज का उच्चारण है एस हो या
इडब्ल्यूएस या फिर ब्रेड को तो फिर दूध और
एक दिन में पॉइंट नहीं बनता तो इसलिए हम
दूर जब करते हैं तो उसको एक और इस नहीं
देते मतलब राइट धन है राइज टो ट्रैवल तो
हम दूर राइज टो मेक डबल इस नहीं करते दूर
राइज ठीक करते हैं या फिर हाइड्रेट मतलब
नाम होना तो इस
सऊदी हाईट में वह बीटा के बाद फिर
क्वेश्चन नहीं लगाते कि एडिसन मिक्स है तो
हम ने क्या बोला ऐसा डालकर है तो हम धूप
को सिर्फ इस नही लगाएंगे लॉजिकल है तो यह
हो गया तीसरा चौथा पांचवा टाइप देखते हैं
कि जो इंपॉर्टेंट तुझे चौथा टाइप है उसको
एक्चुअली जो ऑफिशियली बोलते हैं irregular
या स्टार यह स्ट्रांग वर मतलब क्या है कि
जिम कल स्टोन जो होता है वहीं एक्चुअली
चेंज होता है जब अब आप उनको पंच ग्रेट
करते हैं पर अच्छी बात क्या है कि सिर्फ
दूध और रूप को ही होता है जो इशा वीर्य यह
जो रूप है वह वैसे ही रहते हैं लेकिन जंप
लेते हैं इस प्रशन मतलब स्पीक स्पेशल दून
एक्सप्रेस फेयर एक्सप्रेस पर बीएसपी
क्वेश्चन है ज्ञापन मतलब देना इसके बगदून
गिव्स ए गिफ्ट पर यज्ञ एवं जीवनी या फिर
थोड़ा ज्यादा चेंज होने वाला जो है निमन
निमन का इश्क ने मां दूर नेमस हेयर निम्न
पर व्यूअर ने मनीष जी ने मणि तो क्या कर
सकते हो इजी आईडिया क्या है कि जो ऐसे
वर्ड्स है कि आपकी सब बेसिक 1192 में बहुत
ही कम ऐसे वर्जन की लिस्ट है वह अभी मैंने
आपको दी है तो वह वर्ग याद रखो और उसके
साथ उसका दो और ₹1000 अदरक को अभी वह दो
और के रूप में भी बहुत अच्छी क्लियारिटी
है कि सिर्फ एक गैस का डिफरेंस है बट यान
से पर सेंड आप दोनों यह तो बेसिकली आप
क्या याद रखोगे ज्ञापन गिफ्ट्स गिफ्ट
यह प्रश्न स्प्रिट्स पुलिस प्लेयर है ए
स्पेसिफिक यह एक वर्ग के लिए दो एक्स्ट्रा
वर्ष बात कर लिए प्रॉब्लम्स वर्ल्ड रेट
बहुत बड़ी बात नहीं है यह और अपनी आंखों
फोर्थ जो है टाइप उस पर आएंगे कि जिससे
बहुत सारे लोग डरते हैं जो नए जर्मन सीखते
हैं वह अधिग्रहण बार अलवर अर्बन से प्रबल
व परचून की दुकान स्पून थोड़े से अलग
बोलने है दूसरे वर्ष में तीन बार ट्रैफिक
से ट्रेल मतलब टूटने वाले से प्रबल ऐसे और
उसकी जिनके प्रीफिक्स टूटते हैं पहले हम
देखते हैं यह क्या है और फिर उस पर मौजूद
समय लेते हैं पुलिस को उस हुआ खन अवलोकन
मतलब उठना टो वेक अप उसका इंटिरियर क्या
है कॉफी नार्मल हैंड साइड पर जब यह चलता
है तो कैसे चलता है इष्ट व आओ आओ टूटा और
पीछे गैस के चालान
के अधिवक्ता अवधेश में चला गया है वाहन आओ
एक पैन में अगर हम बोलते कि वे न तो वीर
व्वे ऑल आफ थम एंड मिडल थोड़ा कंप्लीट
सकते हैं सबसे बड़ा प्रॉब्लम है तो उन
लोगों को क्या होता है ऐसे कितने और इसी
लिए इसलिए लोगों को यह की प्रॉब्लम होती
थी वो समझ में नहीं देते थे वर आफ वर्ड्स
इसकी ट्रिक देता हूं एक सिंपल है
कि आप वर्ग को है से याद रखो इन लॉ
मिनिस्टर टो इनवाइट of Clans टू मेक आपको
क्या याद रखना है यह जो प्रीफिक्स है जो
आपको दिख रहे हैं और कौन से अधिक को इसमें
आन है आफ थे हाउस है I am not यह अगर फीस
आपके वर्क है तो टूट न सिंपल है कि जब उस
वर्ग को यूज करोगे तब उसका पृथक् तोड़ना
है सिंपल है और फिर नार्मल जैसे उसको पड़ा
है वैसे पढ़ो एक्चुअली जो अच्छे डिक्शनरी
है उनमें वह इससे अलग करके दिया होता है
पर अगर नहीं भी है तो हमको पता है कि
आयोडीन है तो लाइन टूटने वाला है तो इस
लाडल केदार लाइन होगा और वह बनेगा न टूटने
वाला है तो इश्यू आफ - फूंका यह हमको पता
है तो इससे फायदा क्या हुआ वह तो जैसे
आपने पढ़ना था वैसे ही आप याद रखोगी आपको
सिर्फ किया गया रखना है यह प्रीफिक्सेस
अगर इफैक्ट्स आया
क्वाइट सिंपल है कंसेप्ट अगर समझ लोगे तो
बहुत ही इजी है और एक छोटी सी ट्रिप देता
हूं कि अगर को अवॉर्ड भी करना है तो देखो
अगर फोर्थ और फिर गिफ्ट कैसा था कि यहां
पर दो और का फॉर्म चेंज हो रहा था और फिर
क्या था यह ट्रेन नंबर तुरंत खासियत क्या
है इंफिनिटिव में तो वह नॉर्मल ही भी है
वह कर रहे हैं तो उनको इंफिनिटिव में रखो
मोड व्याख्यान का यूज कर ओए मतलब फॉर
एग्जांपल दुकान से दवाई डिप्रेशन दुकान से
दो एक्सप्रेशन स्पेशल ऑपरेशन गु्रप को
टेंशन ही नहीं है या फिर इस मुसम नाइन
व्वे कंधों फक्र फक्र है या फिर इस
व्यवस्था के द्वारा इंग्लैंड इस मिनट तक
इधर आयोडीन सिंपल साइड पर गिवर है भी नहीं
तो इतना ज्यादा टेंशन
कॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं है हर लैंग्वेज
में थोड़े irregular वर्ग होते हैं जैसे
जैसे आप यह लैंग्वेज ज्यादा यूज करते
जाओगे वैसे-वैसे वह इससे होता जाएगा हर
रोज इसमें से दो तीन जो ए स्ट्रांग वर्ड्स
है वह पढ़ो और यह जो प्रीफिक्सेस मैंने
बताया थे है वह अगर आपने याद रखिए तरह बार
और टूटेंगे तो एकदम सिंपल है तो आप हमने 5
देखिए रेगुलर वर्ग के पहले दो थे सावन
साहिल और मोड वह को आते थे तीसरा यह और भी
लॉजिकल था कि अगर डीटीएम के बाद अगर आए तो
दो और एग के लिए अगस्त काम हो आप कर तो और
बेटे एग्जांपल याद रखो तो इजी हो कर और
अगर आप इसका उच्चारण में है तो दो के लिए
इसकी नहीं लगाया हाफिज और फोर्थ हमने देखा
कुछ ऐसे वर्ड्स होते हैं क्यों कस्टम चेंज
होता है और वह लकी अली सिर्फ दो और रूपों
को चेंज होता है
हैं तो हम उनके है तो वैभव लिए याद रखेंगे
और लास्ट हमने देखा कि रहनुमा बन तो उनके
ट्रिक क्या है तीर वर्ग बंद करके यार मत
रखो बर्फ बन विद ट्रेन वृक्ष याद रखो एक
बार आपको चकमक फिक्स समझ में आ गए तो का
काम हो गया मुझे आशा है कि आप सबको एक
कंसेप्ट समझ में आई होगी हम फिर मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद